this is the road to the puno region of
Southern Peru
a humanitarian truce is supposed to be
in place to allow food and fuel through
along the 400 kilometer route from the
Andean city of Cusco
the road has been blocked for nearly a
month by indigenous communities they
tell us they're outraged about the
deaths of more than 50 protesters almost
all of them here in southern Peru since
president dinabolarte took office in
December
we want all this to change we want
boluarte out we want the Congress out we
women are going to fight till the very
end
through southern Andean region is worlds
apart from the capital or the Norse this
is home to poor mostly indigenous
farmers and miners who voted for Peru's
now deposed president Pedro Castillo but
his removal they tell me is no longer
what's feeding a regional Uprising
Peru is rich in natural resources but
what good does it do us we get no
support from the government from the
sale of our minerals and gas we're still
as poor as our ancestors that's why
we're finally rising up
the traffic starts moving but not for
long well so much so much for the
24-hour truth this road is blocked no
one's going forward or backwards we're
to the front to see if there's any
chance they'll let us pass
[Applause]
a single one of us is a terrorist or
being paid by drug traffickers like the
government says we are here out of
conviction
eventually a few of us are allowed to
pass but only to the next roadblock the
people on this side aren't letting
anybody pass even though they really
don't have that much to stop us but it
underscores the fact that there is no
Central leadership here
the closer we get to puno the bigger the
roadblocks people cart or drag their
goods as best they can but they don't
complain this protest is taking place 24
hours a day each Community takes turns
blocking the road
the protesters hear the news that
Congress has just refused again to meet
their demand for immediate national
elections a clear sign that like traffic
on this road Peru's acute political
conflict is at a standstill Lucia Newman
Al Jazeera in the puno region Peru